hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freund ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen seinem wie
auf dass ich mich wirklich sehr sehr
doll freue er denn vor einigen Tagen
habe ich euch bereits im ersten Teil die
auf meinem Kanal hochgeladen wie ich
mich selber bei Ebay Kleinanzeige
angemeldet habe und ein bisschen Leute
veräppelt habe ich habe keine Kosten und
Mühen gescheut kosten generell nicht
weil das kostet ja nichts allerdings
habe ich keine Mühen gescheut und auch
kein Fremdschaden gefühlt und habe mich
einfach mal wieder in die Welt von Ebay
bewegt um Leute weiter zu veräppeln
[Musik]
ich muss halt der ganzen Welt Millionen
außen
ganze Geld muss ja irgendwo hin
Corona Zeiten hätte man das ganze wohl
noch in Klopapier investiert die Million
oder Taschentücher
und darin, aus und direkt so eine E-Mail
war man die Überleitung schlecht hier
verkauft jemand auf jeden Fall Lindemann
Herren Taschentücher und ich habe
daraufhin gefragt heiß wurden die
Taschentücher schon benutzt hi Luca die
sind noch nie benutzt worden viele Grüße
okay dann will ich sie nicht
[Musik]
ich hab so Schiss das Karma einfach
Streit und ich werde morgen vom Blitz
getroffen oder so einem nächsten ebay
fail bzw Gmail sondern bei der nächsten
ebay-anzeige der playlist an
Unterhaltung danach ja immer allerdings
wird auf jeden Fall ein Elefantenfamilie
verkauft allerdings nur Mutter und Kind
gesehen habe ich gefragt was ist mit dem
Vater passiert ich hatte immer nur die
beiden
das arme Kind
und deine
Figur
bin ich komisch weil dieser
Nächstenliebe Anzeige verkauft jemand
Stühle Keller
habe ich nicht so richtig verstanden
deswegen hab ich gefragt dürfen die
Stühle nur im Keller stehen und er
einfach nicht mehr geantwortet mich wohl
blockiert aber warum wo Wehrdienst
gerade schon mal im Stuhl Thema sind
meine lieben Freunde oder rede ich nicht
von dem Zeug was sind aus dem Arschloch
rauskommt ich habe mir auf jeden Fall
gedacht ich habe aber danach spülen mit
dieser hier
Styrol 5 Leerzeichen. Leerzeichen
Leerzeichen Leerzeichen drei Weise
Leerzeichen zwei Leerzeichen
black.... Und dass ich habe mir dann
gedacht ich passe mich den ganzen mal so
ein bisschen an und schreib daraufhin
auf dem Bild sind nur vier Stück wohl ja
drei weiß 2 black okay this ist echt ein
schöner Tisch ja alles ganz neue
ich würde den Stuhl gegen Deutschbuch
tauschen bei diesem Angebot hat jemand
eine Last Minute
Weihnachtsgeschenk für Freundin oder
Mutter verkauft und ich habe daraufhin
mir gedacht Mensch Weihnachtsgeschenk
meinst du ich kann das meiner Freundin
auch zum Geburtstag schenken ist echt
last minute jetzt ja klar kann ich mir
gut vorstellen allein die checken das
alle nicht ne war halt solche jo weil da
steht last minute so von wegen Haushalt
auf eBay das Elsass belade deswegen habe
ich einen Job gemacht und dann auch noch
Weihnachtsgeschenke frag auch kann ich
das zum Geburtstag schenken
ich so
wieder einfach eine Person also ich nehm
ich hab das wirklich nicht die juckt
mich scheißegal ob das mal wie Kinder
mal oder wird weiß ich es aber die
Person einfach das hier geschrieben
ich habe gedacht wegen Mutter und damit
das halt versteht dachte ich halt so
fürsorglich und Mamas kochen immer gut
ich will auch blockiert
nach wie viel Blockierungen wird man
eingesperrt von eBay die hat jemand ein
elektrisches Mercedes Kinderauto
verkauft und ich habe daraufhin gefragt
wie viele Kilometer sind das schon drauf
so logischerweise wieder als Joker meint
und die Antwort kam einfach maximal 0,5
km nur zweimal Straße hoch und runter
und heute noch 9 Akku verbaut ja
ich würde dir mit deutschen auf eBay
Kleinanzeigen zu schreiben die sind
einfach viel zu lieb die geben die Infos
über alles die einfach keinen Humor
funny gewesen
er muss jetzt inserieren aber wenn du
mir einfach so geantwortet hätte mit dem
Auto damals mir ganze Familie nach
Spanien gefahren am 1968 und noch eine
Weltreise
hat auch schon fünf hinter sich und
keine Ahnung was alles ist so funny
gewesen hätte ich so lustig unterhalten
kann aber irgendwie checke dass niemand
hier auch da verkauft die mich jemand
ein Barbie Auto Fiat 500 also auch
wieder so ein Spielzeugauto ich habe
daraufhin adida gefragt wie viele
Kilometer Kometen wie viele Kilometer
ist der schon gefahren natürlich
gefragt.
[Musik]
ich brauche die nur bis mein
Foto geschickt die sind von 2019 ist
dein Privat verkauft und es gibt leider
von meiner Seite karandi kein ich kann
nicht mehr reden ne
es halt mitten in der Nacht egal ich
habe auf jeden Fall geschrieben kann ich
die bis Mai mieten also es ist ja
logischerweise in Joke in ein Mann der
keine Winterreifen mieten so hä dann
aber geantwortet ich verkaufe nicht
mieten
die checken das alle nicht dass ich das
nicht ernst meine sie hat jemand die
Vampirschwestern 2 als DVD verkaufen und
da ich natürlich die Vampirschwestern 1
noch nicht geguckt habe habe ich
geschrieben heiß den ich habe den ersten
Teil von Vampirschwestern noch nicht
gesehen könntest du mir das kurz
zusammenfassen hallo das kann ich leider
auch nicht ich habe den ersten Teil auch
nicht gesehen viele Grüße die Story vom
ersten Teil denn wichtig für den zweiten
Teil hallo das weiß ich leider auch
nicht DVDs von meinem Enkelkind ich kann
sie fragen ob sie war ich kann nicht
mehr reden
ich kann nicht mehr reden wollen
allerdings auch schon zum vorletzten
ebay Unterhaltungs Fell fürs heutige
video den fand ich wirklich extrem wird
sie und zwar verkauft hat jemand eine
Regenjacke Übergangsjacke ich habe
daraufhin gefragt kann man die Jacke
auch bei gutem Wetter tragen liebe Grüße
ja ich kann dir gerne ein Foto von innen
schicken also gut für Frühjahr-Sommer
würde ich sagen ich habe danach nur
geschrieben nee sorry ich will nur eine
Regenjacke
es ist so wie wenn du so ein Auto kaufen
willst lies die man kennt wenn man Rente
zum Auto kaufen will aber schnell bevor
du bist ein Auto kaufen und dann fragt
sie was dagegen Sitzheizung sagt sie ja
Sitzheizung und Sitzkühlung gesagt zum
Lesen und brauche ich nicht will ich
nicht ich will nur Sitzheizung haben da
drin kommen allerdings auch schon zur
letzten ebay Unterhaltung meine Lieben
freuen und zwar wurde dort eines
Spielzeug Toilette verkauft und zwar
eine Kinder Toilette von Fisher Price
ich habe daraufhin gefragt wie oft wurde
die benutzt also genauso bei den Autos
einfach fragen wie viele Kilometer sind
damit schon gefahren worden und die
Person hat einfach wieder völlig ernst
geantwortet hallo Luca die Toilette
wurde ein halbes Jahr lang benutzt die
Toilette würde gründlich gereinigt und
desinfiziert
dann würde ich dir nicht
so einfach ist es
wo dann auch einfach blockiert
aber gut meine lieben Freunde wenn euch
die heutige Episode Luca
treibt Schabernack auf ebay
kleinanzeigen gefallen hat dann lasst
gerne einen Daumen Hoch unterliegen
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke wenn ihr weitere das nicht
verpassen wollt habt ihr Bock auf den
dritten Teil ich schreibe mit
irgendwelchen komischen Menschen auf
Ebay und niemand versteht mein Humor
dann schreibst du und in die Kommentare
und jetzt sehen uns im Auto
könnt ihr
nicht ob wir wissen mittlerweile wieder
so läuft ne ich habe ein Kanal
abonnieren noch kein Abonnent seit kann
ich euch auch nicht empfehlen besser
lassen und ihr könnt euch auch noch ein
anderes wieder angucken kann ich euch
auch nicht empfehlen denn man hat
definitiv bessere Dinge zu tun aktuell